da da it's a heap train
so much hype low on ranch thanks for
subbing
and theo four and pems
is your first stream welcome to twitch
i love you too
yeah so if you're if you're watching in
real time
you can uh you can challenge me in real
time
60 64 people are challenging me right
now so i think what i'll do
i'll play a random viewer to start
things off
and then then i'll play a random sub
after this game
i'll switch it up a little bit okay
playing k
gun so the goal for this stream is to
play
a different opening in every game
i kind of want to start with a stafford
stafford gambit time
this will be my only staffer gambit the
stream
opponent kind of knows what to oh
opponent plays f3
what is f3 f3 is kind of logical
still go for this f5
so i'll admit i don't really know so
much theory here i just know that black
should
do things along the files
um and kind of appreciate the
lean development oh the magic line
didn't denied yeah
yeah i saw jonathan shawn streaming he
was doing magical things
i won't be able to stay for long today
because i
have to prepare for calc three
well good luck with that yeah i know
there's
maybe more important things in life than
watching me play stafford gambits
i took calc 3 back in 20
was it 2013.
i took calc 3 and then i switched majors
i wasn't so fond of
so many dimensions let's play f4
love the creative chess streams keep it
up oh thanks so much
sponge human oh maybe sponge human is
related to spongebob
thank you sponge human subbing for two
months
i actually really enjoyed calc 2 though
calc 2 i
um i think i got like an a minus
and the professor was a tough creator so
i was happy with it
i have knight g3 here look at this move
my g3 it's a fork and it's a pin
so it's pork
[Music]
okay life is good also yeah thank you
again titan thighs who is second in the
chat
good luck with everything stay calm oh
wait
oh it's a counter pin
uh i guess i'm not oh i have this move
though
oh so many plot twists i have this move
and now it's a trap there's so many
tactics
so i hit white with a pork i got pinned
and now i just calmly move away and now
the rook is trapped
and the pond is still pinned so i'm
winning material
oh except no i'm not oh what a move i
forgot i was pinned
as an additional pin oh that's so sad
i guess i have to take and then cry
i wanted to take on f3
oh this is sad
what oh pin
yeah pins ever yeah
more pins and porks
i should probably take the thing is
i should probably take
so i have i have the bishop hair white
just has one big pawn island
white's also up a pawn but
okay dark sprays are kind of nice for me
this bishop is sad
always have to look on the right side of
things
yeah pin wrap
pin clap
about to get pin slapped wait what
oh that's a battery but it doesn't do
anything
i have this move
okay hi how's it going penguin
in black can i play this move this
pawn's a bit
tender oh oh the pawn's pinned now
let's go but how do i
how do i punish white for being
ah there's 92 oh i was trying mate but
wait do i have mate here ah
robocalls let's do this and
hope it works oh it's so close to
working
i don't know if it works though i can't
resist
there goes my rook it looks so much fun
look at the king king has to move here
or night here maybe
and i can take king's still a target
as opposed to walmart
yeah these pieces aren't really doing
anything it's a sideways frown
i play this move
[Music]
yeah this bishop is such a monster on f4
it restricts like everything
i played b4 to prevent the king from
moving back
but how to how to make progress
probably just have to move quickly let's
play this move
wow look here
let's go i want to play this move
or that move oh it was another pin
and now it's a windmill
okay now it's just gonna be mate
what a game that was a fun game
that's a fun game to start things off
there were a lot of pins that game
like all yeah that was the pins were
everywhere
this was a pin and then later
this was a pin and then earlier
so i got so excited
maybe i got too excited or over excited
in this position thinking i was winning
material
but not realizing white's counter pins
because i saw i saw this pin i just
didn't see
these other pins hip hip hooray
yeah hip hip more like pin pin hooray
yeah this is kind of a sad moment all i
have to do is like move my queen
somewhere
to keep the pin and not get counter
pinned
but this is really only square
i really don't know what to make of that
thank you
numbers oh wait
is that an equation to solve alexa
what's 24 times 36
24 times 36 is 864. oh
thank you 864 for the bits
uh i'm just curious like was i
better here or was i worse maybe keep up
that white still better
or maybe oh congratulations
baby who was that
seaghost congratulations okay yeah i
have a lot of people to think
but yeah so stockfish still prefers
white here even though i got this move
in
but it was a fun position and this is
usually how you should reply
to like an early f3 eric first time
catching your stream glad to finally be
here
oh good to have you here wait no this is
not your first time i've played you
before
silo simon but welcome
and good to have you
uh
yeah very rarely do i see d3 and then f3
um it white plays f3 it's usually in
this position
but yeah we kind of went into
some fun fun stuff
and then there is a moment here this
position i was shutting meat
you got me oh did i play no
oh oh i got you because yeah you were
trying to get away with a
false statement but thanks for the bits
yeah i was hoping for 92 and then it's
not me but i win the night
anyway that was a fun game probably
youtube worthy
i don't know what i'll call it maybe
something
stafford gambit or pins everywhere
have to brainstorm some names but people
on youtube
hit subscribe we're closing in on 200
000 subscribers
also you can follow on twitch if you
want to watch in in real time